ya sabemos que si partimos de una
molécula de glucosa que es una molécula
que tiene 6 átomos de carbono 1 2 3 4 5
6 entonces a través de la glucólisis
podemos generar dos moléculas de
piruvato de piruvato o también podríamos
considerar el ácido bird ubico verdad
tenemos dos moléculas de piruvato y cada
una de estas moléculas tiene tres átomos
de carbono muy bien entonces obviamente
hay muchas otras cosas unidas a estos a
estos átomos de carbono verdad y ya lo
hemos visto anteriormente y si no
también pueden verlo con más detalle en
wikipedia pero lo importante es que esta
molécula de glucosa fue cortada digamos
en dos partes a través del proceso de la
glucólisis
a través de la glucólisis y algo
importante que hay que mencionar de la
glucólisis es que puede ocurrir en
ausencia de oxígeno o también puede
ocurrir ante la presencia de oxígeno les
digamos el punto importante es que no
necesita oxígeno para llevarse a cabo
verdad y también otra cuestión
importante que hay que mencionar es que
al final tenemos una ganancia de 2 atp
netos y cuando digo 2 atp es netos estoy
pensando en que en digamos tenemos dos
fases es verdad una fase de inversión en
donde necesitamos 2 atp es para poder
iniciar la glucólisis y tenemos una fase
de recompensa en donde obtenemos 4 atp
es así que en total obtenemos 2 atp
netos verdad y también tenemos la
producción de dos moléculas de línea de
muy bien todo eso lo obtuvimos de la
glucólisis y para poder visualizar lo
voy a dibujar una célula por aquí
digamos aquí tenemos una célula desde su
membrana externa verdad y vamos a
suponer que esta célula tiene un núcleo
verdad y en ese núcleo se encontrará el
adn verdad y entonces si tiene el núcleo
verdad estamos pensando que es una
célula eucariota muy bien entonces ésta
va a tener aquí también unas
mitocondrias estas mitocondrias tienen
su membrana externa y la membrana
interna verdad aquí vamos a poner otra
otra mitocondria
otra mitocondria y a las mitocondrias
suelen llamarles como el centro de
energía de la célula verdad pero eso lo
vamos a ver en otro vídeo verdad no lo
vamos a ver más adelante ok entonces ahí
tenemos las mitocondrias y en y en
general los organelos verdad se
encuentran en un espacio con fluido
verdad y cada uno de estos órganos
cumple alguna función específica en la
célula verdad así como los órganos
tienen una función para nuestro cuerpo
aquí tenemos este espacio fluido entre
los organelos y ya es a ese digamos a
ese fluido o ese espacio fluido le
conocemos como sito sol sito sol muy
bien y es importante mencionar el cito
sol porque es en esta parte en donde se
lleva a cabo la glucólisis aquí se lleva
a cabo la glucólisis muy bien y de hecho
en otro vídeo ya vimos cuál sería el
siguiente paso después de la glucólisis
y es el ciclo de creps o también
conocido como el ciclo del ácido
y este ocurre en la membrana interna de
la mitocondria y sólo para ser claros
voy a dibujar una mitocondria más grande
muy bien entonces digamos aquí tenemos
nuestra mitocondria que era la que
teníamos en verde aquí y esta
mitocondria tiene una membrana externa y
también tiene una membrana interna
verdad aquí tenemos nuestra membrana
interna y a estos pliegues que tiene la
membrana interna se les da un nombre y
se les conoce como crestas estas son las
crestas muy bien y podemos notar que
aquí tenemos como dos especies de
compartimentos este que estoy pintando
con rojo es digamos como el
compartimento externo verdad y a éste se
le conoce como el espacio inter
membranoso inter
enter membranoso
para
eso es digamos como el espacio externo y
por supuesto también tenemos como un
compartimento interno verdad este
compartimento de acá que también recibe
el nombre y se le conoce como matriz
ésta es la matriz de la mitocondria
ahora bien regresemos a estos piratas
tenemos estos dos pilotos que se
producen a partir de la glucosa en la
glucólisis verdad pero éstos no se
encuentran del todo listos para entrar
al ciclo de krebs así que como los
preparamos para que entren al ciclo
bueno en esencia vamos a tener que
oxidar los así que sólo me voy a centrar
en uno de los pilotos verdad pero
recuerden que todo esto que voy a
mencionar a partir de este momento va a
ocurrir dos veces es verdad dos veces
pues tenemos dos moléculas de piruvato
que se producen por cada molécula de
glucosa así que vamos a tener digamos
vamos a tener a partir de este momento
un estado preparatorio para entrar al
ciclo de krebs y este comienza con la
oxidación del piruvato y esencialmente
lo que va a hacer este paso es remover
un carbono de este piruvato verdad
terminando con un compuesto con una
estructura principal digamos de 2
carbonos verdad porque recuerden aquí
hay muchas otras cosas unidas a estos
carbonos pero bueno a este nuevo
compuesto de 2 carbonos le conocemos
como acetil coa así que vamos a
escribirlo este será el acetil co
muy bien y es una molécula que tiene dos
carbonos vamos a ponerlo así tiene
digamos una estructura principal de dos
carbonos y entonces a este proceso de
generar acetil coa a partir del piruvato
le conocemos como la oxidación
justamente del piruvato oxidación del
piruvato muy bien y algo muy importante
que hay que remarcar de este proceso es
que vamos a tener la formación de nh a
partir de enea además tenemos n además
que se va a reducir en nh porque gana un
hidrógeno muy bien entonces este proceso
generalmente se incluye en el ciclo de
creerse en algunos libros de texto
digamos pero en realidad es un estado
preparatorio para el ciclo de krebs muy
bien una vez que ya tenemos este este
compuesto de la cee tylko a que tiene
dos átomos de carbono verdad una vez que
ya tenemos el acetil coa entonces
estamos listos para entrar al ciclo de
krebs y veremos en unos segundos por qué
se dice que es un ciclo bueno entonces
ahora algo importante que hay que
mencionar es que todo esto va a ser
catalizado por enzimas las enzimas son
proteínas que se encargan de juntar todo
el material necesario y digamos
juntarlo de la forma correcta para que
en efecto puedan reaccionar en
particular el acetil coa digamos va a
ser catalizado por enzimas verdad y se
va a unir a un ácido oxálico entonces
vamos a escribir esto vamos a poner el
ácido
ha sido ox halo acético köksal o acético
aquí tenemos el ácido oxálico y dejamos
así yo sé que es una palabra muy
rimbombante pero esta es una molécula
esencialmente que tiene 4 carbonos
verdad o al menos una estructura
principal de 4 carbonos y estas dos
reaccionan digamos catalizados por
enzimas todo esto va a ser catalizado
por enzimas es importante que lo
recordemos por si no se viene en algún
examen y te preguntan es una reacción de
catálisis enzimática y entonces la
respuesta es si todo en el ciclo de
krebs son reacciones de catálisis
enzimática es verdad entonces podemos
pensar que estos dos pues se van a
juntar estos estas dos moléculas se van
a juntar vamos a hacer estas flechas un
poco más grandes estas dos moléculas se
van a juntar y van a formar
ácido cítrico o si trato muy bien
entonces tenemos la formación de ácido
cítrico ácido cítrico que esencialmente
es
mismo que tú puedes encontrar en la
limonada o en el jugo de naranja verdad
y esta es nuevamente una molécula de 6
átomos de carbono muy bien son 1 2 3 4 5
de ahí que digamos en realidad es porque
tenemos cuatro del ácido oxálico y dos
del acetil ccoo
muy bien entonces es una molécula de 6
átomos de carbono y digamos después el
ácido cítrico es oxidado a través de
varios pasos verdad y ésta es una gran
simplificación lo que voy a hacer a
continuación de lo que es la oxidación
del ácido cítrico en donde se van a
eliminar dos átomos de carbono para
tratar de hacer esta flecha
ok vamos a tener varios pasos para
oxidar el ácido cítrico y regresar
esencialmente al ácido oxálico acético
muy bien y entonces uno podría
preguntarse qué es lo que le va a
ocurrir a todos estos carbonos que se
están perdiendo en todos estos pasos
verdad y la respuesta es que todos esos
carbonos se transforman en dióxido de
carbono y abandonan el sistema entonces
por ejemplo aquí nosotros tenemos que
del piruvato a la acetil coa perdemos un
carbono y ese carbono se va a convertir
en dióxido de carbono y va a abandonar
el sistema muy bien aquí es en donde se
forma dióxido de carbono de forma
similar cuando los carbonos digamos en
este paso del ácido cítrico al ácido
oxálico verdad se van a perder dos
carbonos y esos dos carbonos se van a
liberar en forma de dióxido de carbono
muy bien
pero no tenemos lo siguiente por cada
molécula de glucosa vamos a tener tres
moléculas de dióxido de carbono que se
van a liberar verdad pero eso ocurre dos
veces verdad porque tenemos dos
moléculas de piruvato verdad entonces
duplicamos esto y concluimos que son
seis moléculas de dióxido de carbono los
que se van a liberar verdad entonces en
realidad nos deshacemos de 6 dióxido de
carbono por cada 2 moléculas de piruvato
verdad entonces estos se cuentan digamos
por x cada uno de los carbonos que se
están liberando en todos estos procesos
ahora bien retomando de nuevo el ciclo
de creerse en realidad no solo se va a
liberar dióxido de carbono sino que
también va a producir otras moléculas
verdad por ejemplo se va a producir nada
nh fadh 2 y atp muy bien esto en
realidad va a ser una gran
simplificación les mostraré con más
detalle más adelante qué es lo que
ocurre pero digamos en primero en el
ciclo de krebs vamos a tener la
reducción de enea de más en nh aquí
tenemos la reducción de n además en n
de h muy bien y esto se repite otra vez
digamos en esta parte del ciclo aquí
tenemos también nh que se redujo a
partir de enea de más verdad y no
pierdan de vista que esto es una una
simplificación de todo el ciclo por
supuesto hay muchos otros compuestos
intermedios que les mostraré más
adelante pero bueno aquí también vamos a
tener la producción de una molécula de
atp verdad vamos a convertir una
molécula de adp en una de atp tenemos
eso también vamos a tener la reducción
de una molécula de f a d
efe ade en una molécula de efe a de h2
bien eso es una reducción porque ghana
hidrógenos después de esto vamos a tener
también la producción de un nh a partir
de enea de más n además se reduce en nh
y regresamos al ácido oxálico acético
para poder repetir todo el ciclo
entonces no hay que perder de vista la
producción de nh y fadh 2 porque esos
van a ser útiles en la cadena de
transporte de electrones y es en ese
paso en donde la gran mayoría de los atp
se van a producir a lo largo de la
respiración celular muy bien ahora bien
para ser claros vamos a dividir con
líneas los procesos que hemos estado
viendo verdad entonces esto que tenemos
a la izquierda de digamos esta línea que
estoy pintando aquí va a ser la
glucólisis estos digamos del lado
izquierdo va a ser la glucólisis
la glucólisis
y en varios libros de texto todo lo que
se encuentra a la derecha de esta línea
se considera el ciclo de krebs aunque
existe esta fase digamos esta fase
preparatoria que pues es eso es una fase
preparatoria para poder entrar al ciclo
de krebs luego el ciclo de creer es
justamente digamos todo este mecanismo
que comienza con el acetil con la verdad
se mezcla con el ácido oxálico verdad y
se va a transformar en ácido cítrico
este se va a oxidar verdad con toda una
serie de pasos que van a terminar
produciendo atp ya sea directamente o
indirectamente en la cadena de
transporte de electrones muy bien así
que ya que tenemos todo este panorama
digamos vamos a contar todo lo que
tenemos entonces en la glucólisis
nosotros ya habíamos contado que
teníamos
atp netos verdad y tendríamos también 2n
a de h verdad ahora en el ciclo de krebs
tenemos la oxidación del piruvato verdad
o al menos en esta fase preparatoria
que produce un gene a h1n a de h verdad
y esto es sólo por un piruvato y sabemos
que la glucólisis produjo en realidad
dos piruvato es verdad así que todo lo
que tenemos a partir de este momento lo
tenemos que multiplicar por 2 vamos a
ponerlo aquí verdad todo lo que tenemos
a partir de este momento lo tenemos que
multiplicar por 2 porque tenemos dos
moléculas de piruvato verdad y eso
ocurre por cada molécula de glucosa con
la que iniciamos así que tenemos 2
nh en realidad tenemos digamos vamos a
ponerlo aquí tenemos una línea de h por
cada molécula de piruvato pero tenemos
de ellos así que en total terminamos con
dos n
de h muy bien por otro lado ya en el
ciclo de krebs tenemos una idea de h2 n
de h3c nh tenemos tres moléculas de nh
pero tenemos que multiplicarlo
nuevamente por dos verdad entonces
déjenme bajar un poco tenemos tres n a
de h pero hay que multiplicarlo por dos
pues este ciclo se repite una vez por
cada molécula de piruvato que tenemos y
eso nos da un total de 6 n a de h muy
bien
6 d
muy bien también tenemos la producción
de una molécula de atp verdad tenemos
una molécula de atp que también hay que
multiplicar por dos y entonces obtenemos
dos moléculas de atp y finalmente
también tenemos una molécula de efe a de
h2 que hay que multiplicar por 2 también
para obtener en total dos moléculas de f
de h2 entonces aquí está el resumen de
todo lo que obtenemos hasta este momento
verdad y como mencionamos en algunos
libros de texto digamos esta etapa
preparatoria lo incluyen dentro del
ciclo de krebs verdad entonces en ese
caso en esos libros estarían contando 8
nh que se producen en todo este en toda
esta parte verdad serían estos 2 que
tenemos aquí más estos 6 que tenemos acá
serían 8 nh en el ciclo de krebs pero la
verdad es que hay que dividirlo verdad
son 2 cnh que se generan en la etapa
preparatoria y 6 que se generan en el
ciclo de krebs muy bien ahora vamos a
ver si podemos llegar a los 38 a tps
prometidos ya dijimos que teníamos 2 atp
producidos en la glucólisis y 2 atp que
se producen en el ciclo de creerse eso
nos da un total de 4 atp vamos a ponerlo
acá abajo
4 atp es cuál
atp es verdad y también tenemos la
producción de docena de h en la
glucólisis 2nd h en la etapa
preparatoria y 6 cnh
en el ciclo de krebs entonces eso nos da
un total de dos y dos son cuatro y seis
son diez
nh 10 n
h y finalmente tenemos 2 fadh 2 verdad 2
de h2 entonces la pregunta esencial es
cómo conseguimos 38 atp a partir de todo
esto verdad y lo que podemos observar
fácilmente es que aquí ya tenemos 4 atp
muy bien entonces estas moléculas que
tenemos acá se van a oxidar en la cadena
de transporte de electrones y por su
parte los 10
nh van a producir 30 atp
entonces estos de aquí van a producir 30
atp es cuando estemos en la cadena de
transporte de electrones mientras que
los fadh van a producir 4 atp muy bien
van a producir 4 atp en la k en la
cadena
a cadena de transporte de electrones así
que si hacemos el conteo tenemos 4 atp
de la glucólisis y el ciclo de krebs y
tenemos estos 34 atp es que se producen
en la cadena de transporte de electrones
entonces si hacemos la suma verdad si
hacemos aquí la suma tenemos un total de
38 atp es que son los 38 atp es
prometidos de la respiración celular
verdad y recuerden este número es solo
un máximo teórico no todas las células
llegan a producir 38 atp es verdad
depende de la eficiencia de todos los
procesos que involucran esta formación
de atp y ahora otro punto importante que
quiero mencionar es que todo esto que
hemos mencionado hasta aquí
esencialmente es el catabolismo de la
glucosa verdad en realidad estamos
rompiendo la glucosa para producir la
atp es verdad la glucosa en este caso
sería nuestro punto de inicio pero los
animales incluyen
a nosotros los seres humanos también
podemos catalizar otras cosas por
ejemplo podemos catalizar proteínas
verdad podemos catalizar proteínas
también podemos catalizar grasas grasas
verdad si uno tiene grasa en su cuerpo
entonces tenemos energía verdad en
realidad nuestro cuerpo debería ser
capaz de tomar estas grasas y
aprovecharlos para generar atp muy bien
y la razón por la cual menciono todo
esto es porque aunque la glucólisis no
es de utilidad para estas biomoléculas
verdad aunque aunque las grasas pueden
convertirse en glucosa en el hígado por
ejemplo lo interesante es que el ciclo
de krebs es el punto de entrada para
estos otros mecanismos catabólico es
verdad
las proteínas pueden romperse en
aminoácidos que a su vez pueden romperse
y formar acetil
muy bien las grasas por su parte pueden
convertirse en glucosa y después seguir
toda la respiración celular verdad pero
pero lo importante es que el acetil coa
es digamos como el intermediario que
después puede entrar al ciclo de creer
sin importar cuál era nuestro y
digámoslo así cuál era nuestro
combustible verdad podrían haber sido
carbohidratos podrían haber sido por
proteínas o podrían haber sido grasas
verdad y sabemos muy bien cómo funciona
todo esto ahora bien voy a mostrarles un
diagrama de wikipedia digamos que quiero
mostrárselos y que observen lo confuso
que puede llegar a ser verdad todo esto
es un diagrama del ciclo de krebs y
quizás esta es la razón por la cual a
muchos de nosotros nos cuesta trabajo la
respiración celular en realidad es mucha
información que procesar el diagrama
tiene mucha información pero aquí quiero
destacar digamos la información más
importante de este proceso muy bien
entonces podemos ver aquí
de la glucólisis se producen dos
moléculas de piruvato verdad son dos
pilotos que de hecho aquí está su
estructura molecular verdad y de aquí
pasamos a la etapa preparatoria verdad
que es justamente cuando vamos a oxidar
el piruvato en acetil co
muy bien y vemos de hecho que aquí se
produce el dióxido de carbono y también
se redujo en 'además en línea de h voy a
ponerle un poquito mejor
aquí tenemos línea de h muy bien luego
podremos ya entrar al ciclo de krebs
verdad el ácido oxálico aquí lo tenemos
el ácido oxálico y el acetil co se van a
digamos van a reaccionar para producir
ácido cítrico aquí tenemos el ácido
cítrico citrato y de hecho aquí está su
estructura molecular aquí está dibujada
la molécula y luego el ácido cítrico es
oxidado a través de varios pasos que es
el ciclo de krebs
todo esto son los pasos mediante los
cuales se va a oxidar el ácido cítrico
verdad y todo esto recordemos todos
estos pasos se van a realizar con la
ayuda de enzimas pero vamos a destacar
digamos lo más importante aquí vamos a
tener algunas moléculas de nh
produciéndose verdad por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una molécula de nh que se redujo
a partir de enea de más acá tenemos otra
nh que se redujo a partir de enea demás
y aquí tendremos una última de ellas
verdad que también se redujo de n además
entonces tenemos 3 en total y que junto
con la que se produce en la etapa
preparatoria verdad esta de aquí junto
con esa tenemos 4 n de h en total y 3 de
ellos son directamente del ciclo de
krebs ahora en este diagrama vemos que
el tenemos una molécula que ubicamos
como gtp
gtp y esta se forma a partir de gtp en
realidad el gtp es bueno sin trifosfato
es digamos otra purina que después puede
ser una fuente de energía
pero bueno esencialmente esto
posteriormente puede producir atp muy
bien entonces de aquí esencialmente
después de esto podríamos producir atp
muy bien entonces luego en el diagrama
vemos este grupo q ok tenemos un grupo q
del cual no voy a hablar mucho
simplemente vamos a decir que este grupo
q se va a reducir va a ganar hidrógenos
verdad y es de aquí de donde se van a
obtener los f a de h2 muy bien es de
aquí de donde se van a obtener los fadh
2 entonces en resumen por cada piruvato
nosotros vamos a producir 4 n a dh es
verdad aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 n a de h
tenemos un atp y tenemos un f a de h2
verdad
eso es exactamente lo que vimos acá
arriba verdad tendríamos nuestros 3 cnh
más uno de preparatorio verdad tendremos
un atp tendremos un fadh 2 es
exactamente lo que estamos viendo en el
diagrama bueno nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo